[Music]
what's going on guys it's back to school
month end of summer
no more bikini season and time to
recount summer box office we had some
great cinema minds come in a few months
ago to predict the summer box-office top
ten and we were all wrong but we got a
few right let's meet our panel
reconvening great to have him back
Oh welcome back to the show Dan Morelle
thank you no oh she is always fresh
never rotten can I call you the Queen
tomato at Rotten Tomatoes
yes you may great Drake good to see you
and he's an old friend of the show you
know I'm from schmoes no and Collider
movie news Kristian harloff what's up
guys
looking forward to being in last place
now we shall see we'll announce the
results in just a bit
but guys how was your summer at the
movies you had to go to an independent
theater to have any satisfaction this
year she's so right I mean that that is
where it was whether it's hell or high
water or Kubo go stream those were the
movies that really hit that I mean it
had a lot of detail to them it's a very
disappointing summer as far as quality
goes yeah absolutely
so ok let's let's break down the summer
a little bit first off we all had the
incorrect number one film right really
finding dory swam up behind Civil War
and took the number one guy we all said
Civil War and by the way everybody that
entered to the contest 95% of the people
are more all also at Civil War at the
number one spot so almost everybody was
wrong on that okay so what that means is
that superhero movies are totally out
fish movies are in that's it you guys
fish have legs at the box off and it
should be noted not only was dory the
number-one movie of the summer it is the
number one animated film ever which is
insane great I would love to hear your
thoughts on Suicide Squad for those who
don't know the fans of Suicide Squad
went pretty ballistic on your website
Rotten Tomatoes and they tried to shut
it down because the cumulative critics
score was so low let's just shut her
down yes shut me down are the protesters
still there have they left you know what
they've gotten very far
actually we've taken to bringing them
coffee and doughnuts every morning and
critically the movie was about the same
as BBS like the critics generally hated
it
it's like a twenty five ish percentage
for both of the movies and bless that
man in Egypt who started his little
petition and the thing is that I am into
that kind of thing
only because it gets people talking
about criticism and about their opinions
unfortunately that so quickly devolves
into like name-calling and run Tomatoes
is the worst it's like we're just the
messenger guys but we're we're not shut
down you can't shut us down
I think people lose surprise people lose
a little bit of the nuance on the
internet which is that yes the composite
score was similar to Batman V Superman
but I think if they really looked at the
reviews themselves even though a lot of
them listed negative they were actually
I think more enthusiastic than they were
used for Batman V Superman I personally
liked Suicide Squad better and I think
more people even though they might have
been negative were more in the middle so
it was an improvement I think generally
as far as the critics go overall but
it's just that the review still tended
the list to the negative side guys I'd
like to talk about a few of the tentpole
movies that had big opening weekends but
then just kind of close to a stop just
kind of underperform Jason Bourne
Star Trek beyond x-men apocalypse I
think they all won their weekends all
mediocre movies I like Star Trek beyond
yeah you know it actually is yeah that
that was the only one I wish would have
done better because it was one that I
wasn't going to enjoy it as much as I
did I really enjoyed beyond and you
mentioned Jason Bourne I think tried to
give you the same thing that we kind of
seen what I loved about the first three
down hallways guys yeah what I loved
about the first few Jason Bourne movies
were that it was unique it was involved
this was just king generic it there
wasn't anything to it first Rotten
Bourne movie oh really
rotten Wow I still liked it cuz I'll
just watch that stuff I like I find
Jason Bourne movie super watchable even
the Jeremy Renner one wasn't that bad
and I love it when they say the assets
in place I love it when they call a
person they asked but that for me was
the problem with it was he was just
Jason Bourne tropes it was just like
let's put more people in a control room
here's another evil
guy here's another thing that Jason
Bourne forgot about here's another car
chase there was nothing new there was
nothing fresh that's about it and that
was the problem for me it's like there
wasn't anything inherently wasn't wrong
with it it was just let's talk about
some of the big old flops this summer Oh
Spielberg did not have a good outing
with BFG Mark Rylance was amazing in it
the little girl was cute precocious
it just wasn't great yeah I was the only
one that had it on my top ten list and
did not make it yeah just again not a
terrible movie but just nothing special
and like so many other movies and yeah a
lot of farting though so that's
something what's funny about it is that
I'm such a big Spielberg guy I still
haven't seen it I'll wait for blu-ray
and that's exactly what I'm doing
yeah so did everyone else and all the
online players I guess stayed home
playing Warcraft instead of going to see
Warcraft I had that one high up there I
thought a lot of people were gonna go
and check that one out and then I saw it
look do I think it is a terrible movie I
don't I think it's a messy movie there
were so many things wrong with this
movie and I think it was so inside
baseball if you didn't know what was
going on in Warcraft I think people
don't wait what I was watching on people
who knew and they got every reference
and I'm like looking at them like
wanting to explain it and by the time I
wait now if they explain this I'm gonna
miss that it was it was a bit of a mess
there are four sequels that many of us
had on our lists that did not perform
I'll ride home often will uh shoot the
breeze about him dad's in shame yes I'll
write them off we'll hang our heads in
shame
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles to
neighbors to Alice Through the Looking
Glass or Alice 2 and ID for resurgent oh
my god oh yeah I'm actually happy though
for us on that as a people that the id4
didn't make it into that top 10 because
my goodness was that one of the worst
movies I've seen in a long time I for me
it was one of the worst and one of the
best I thought that it delivered
everything that I wanted in the Penn
State sequel and everything I feared
simultaneously in the same movie so many
emotions I had so many emotions I would
like to give America kudos for not going
to see Alice's Looking Glass that a good
job America we all held our nose and put
it on our list and we were wrong and I'm
for once I'm very happy to say that we
were
both Christian and Dan had three of
these bad sequels on their list and gray
you had two of them I would have defend
neighbors too I thought hey bruh Stu was
an equal to the first one I thought it
did something different I thought it was
just as funny and I still think it was a
bad movie dude I'll get your back on
that I went to neighbors too when I
laugh yeah let's talk about a couple of
surprises swinging into the top ten
Tarzan made it yeah did anyone have that
no no why would we have I know I didn't
know if there's any geniuses on this
they certainly wasn't me we're
professionals yes we were not prepared
for the power of Alexander Skarsgard ABS
right but I didn't do that good I was
telling Christians before the show
arguably half the movies on the top ten
aren't even successes right they their
disappointments I think it's just that
I've lesser of Evil's know the lesser of
Evil's the bottom the floor of this
there's six of them I think are in the
hundred millions it's not so much of
these movies or successes it's that
nothing was really a huge hit
the only Tarzan for me is Casper Van
Dien Casper if your watch and I got your
back brother
central intelligence made the top ten
then I was the only one to have it on my
list I gambled on the power of the rock
and Kevin Hart and I came up big I
whipped on San Andreas last year I
whipped on Central Intelligence pull me
once
blow me twice shame on me that that was
never bet against the rock don't
underestimate the power of a little
heart in a big Johnson okay a secret
life of pets number three Wow Dan nailed
that one that I had it at number three
on my list I don't have a lot to hang my
hat on the summer that's my one thing
that I can say that I got right couple
of surprise hits Angry Birds and bad
mom's bad moms that's great news that's
a good solid comedy yeah knocking on the
door at a hundred million dollars bug
your birds went out the top ten like two
weeks ago we almost said it Angry Birds
in the top ten both wow yeah I mean they
both did really well oh one massive flop
that we haven't mentioned yet Ben Hur
yeah though miles came off that chariot
huh why I watch that nobody wanted it it
didn't do anything and improved on the
original nobody was asking for it
obviously nobody wanted to go see it I
don't know why that movie ever got
greenlit that'd be like I'm gonna remake
the Wizard of
also making the top ten a bit of a
controversial film this summer
Ghostbusters gray and I were the only
two to have it in our top ten
ghostbusters to me I think I said it on
the show last time I just think you
could have done a lot more if you just
switch things up a little bit this is a
movie I enjoyed I didn't jump out of my
seat over it it's a movie that I liked
but at the end of the day I thought it
was much abou about nothing
oh I'm just glad it so nailed it a
classic pun a classic pun from Dan Merle
loved to go right down the line and hear
from each of you what was your favorite
film of the summer and biggest
disappointment in your eyes let's start
with Dan Merle while my favorite film
was one that I don't think he came out
in the summer so I was sink Street
really tiny little film from the guy
that directed once I love that movie as
far as the blockbuster movie or a studio
movie I liked Civil War a lot I liked
Kubo in the two strings I thought that
was a really strong movie from Leica but
it's just such a kind of bland generic
summer I actually think that the horror
genre had a great summer I liked don't
breathe I liked lights out and I liked
the conjuring too and I'm not a big fan
of horror movies gotcha
and was biggest disappointment in your
eyes for me just in comparison to the
other films it was Jason Bourne gotcha
great talk to us I want to sing the
praises of the lobster yet again I feel
like all I talked about the summer was
the lobster it's consistent it's
imaginative its inventive Colin Farrell
Rachel Weisz fantastic and I'd say that
in my heart the biggest disappointment
was definitely resurgence I wanted
independence a to be great any
opportunity see Jeff Goldblum but it
just was Liam Hemsworth peeing on the
moon
oh the lesser Hemsworth as I call him
Christian um yeah for favorite I mean I
have to echo Dan as far as overall you
know it's on summer but against sing
Street I think is the best movie of the
year so far but a movie we haven't
talked about thought I think my favorite
summer movie was the nice guys oh yeah
nice guys was a movie that people are
always calling for how come there's not
original movies well you got one he
didn't go and see it as far as the
disappointing ones I'm also with Dan
here on Jason Bourne because I was so
excited to see Jason Bourne like I
really was it was like on my top list
for one of the most anticipated movies
of the
here because they love the first three
so much and it was a letdown but I also
him with gray as far as I wanted
Independence Day to just be dopey fun
like the first one was and it just it
angered me in the theater I do want the
oil painting of Will Smith though that
was hanging in the White House and then
if it is a research those are my
favorite parts of the movie is that a
toil painting Will Smith was hanging in
the White House that's great now without
further ado let's reveal our results
bring up the rear with six of the top
ten films Christian Merlot Sinatra mere
two of us had seven of the top ten films
Dan Merle and gray Drake and one of us
had eight of the top ten summer films I
did it you guys here's my first win how
many times have we done this this is our
fourth time time I did it oh I'll never
forget this moment also we asked you at
home to chime in and give us your top
ten many of you beat all of us and had
nine of the top ten films so it came
down to a tiebreaker which was ranking
order and our winner Adam weaking of
Merritt Island Florida Adam you are a
true screen junkie congratulations you
guys what a summer it's been oh not
really
yeah not really haha that sums it up so
I'll see you at the movies in the fall
yeah yep Dan Merle thanks for coming
across the hall buddy thank you how what
a bummer to do a summer show on this
summer I hope next year is better Judy
Moody's very bummer summer exactly great
Drake always a pleasure to have you
thanks for coming back it's really been
nice sharing the summer of math yeah the
summer of math Kristian harloff very
excited for the Fall I cannot wait for
fall movie particular there we go
and I want to thank you for watching
screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up
on Twitter bye-bye
let's talk about your list great let's
start with you
what's one movie on your list where you
think might sneak up and surprise us god
I hope it's ghostbusters I put it at
number 10 yeah only because the jury's
still out